bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de la théorie des jeux il s'agit d'un
domaine à la frontière entre les
mathématiques et la psychologie où l'on
s'intéresse non pas à des jeux où on
s'affronte 1 comme le poker ou les
échecs mais à toutes ces situations où
plusieurs personnes peuvent être en état
de faire des coopérations et on va voir
que ça concerne pas seulement des jeux
[Musique]
imaginons qu'un braquage viennent
d'avoir lieu
la police a pas beaucoup d'indicés
décide de convoquer les suspects
habituels bonnie & clyde alors fait
bonnie & clyde ont vraiment commis le
braquage
mais comme la police a pas de quoi les
inculpés elle décide de les interroger
séparément et la situation est la
suivante un chacun des deux gangsters
peut décider soit de garder le silence
soit de balancer son complice alors si
les deux se taisent bas la police les
inculpés pour des faits mineurs ils font
chacun un an de prison s'il se dénonce
mutuellement ils sont jugés pour le
braquage et prennent chacun 50 taule
mais si l'un des sites de ce terre et
que son complice le trail en le
dénonçant
eh bien le traître ressort libre et
l'autre fait dix ans de prison donc
voilà les règles du jeu et puis je vous
rappelle les deux sont interrogés
séparément
alors à votre avis qui ont intérêt à
faire bonnie & clyde évidemment
intuitivement ils ont intérêt à se taire
tous les deux ils feront un nom de tôle
bien sûr mais c'est tout sauf que
mettons nous à la place de bonis siclaé
la balance elle a intérêt à le balancer
aussi pour ne faire que cinq ans au lieu
de dix mais si kleitz se tait et voilà
quand même intérêt à le balancer pour
ressortir libre tout de suite au lieu de
faire bêtement un en taule
donc quel que soit le choix de clyde
boni abouti à la conclusion qu'elle a
intérêt à le trahir et évidemment klein
va faire le raisonnement analogue est
lui aussi conclure qu' il a intérêt à
trahir et donc même si on voit bien que
globalement la bonne solution c'est que
les deux coopèrent pour se taire et ben
si chacun résonne dans son coin selon
son propre intérêt les deux ont intérêt
à trahir et ils vont se retrouver donc
dans la pire des situations
cette situation que je viens de vous
décrire s'appelle le dilemme du
prisonnier
elle est représentative des questions
qu'on se pose dans le domaine de la
théorie des jeux alors ce qu'on appelle
un jeu plus généralement c'est une
situation où plusieurs personnes doivent
prendre des décisions et ce qu'ils y
gagnent va dépendre des décisions qui
sont prises par tous les autres alors
l'histoire de bonnie & clyde est une
situation où ils ont quelque chose à
perdre leur année liberté mais plus
généralement on peut présenter des jeux
tout à fait un
où il est question de gains imaginez
deux joueurs et que chacun des deux
doivent faire un choix parmi les options
trahir ou bien coopérer et les gains
seront les suivants si les deux
coopèrent il gagne trois points chacun
s'ils travaillent tous les deux il gagne
un point chacun mais si l'un trahi et
pas l'autre et bien le traître en poche
5 points et l'autre repart les mains
vides
c'est simplement une version enghien de
la situation de bonnie & clyde et même
s'il est plus question de prison pas par
commodité on appelle aussi ce jeu le
dilemme du prisonnier
ce qui rend ce jeu intéressant c'est
qu'il ya une notion de coopération
possible et ça c'est quelque chose qui
n'existe pas dans un jeu comme le poker
par exemple si on joue au poker ensemble
ce que je gagne vous perdez et
réciproquement
on n'a pas d'intérêt à coopérer le poker
est ce qu'on appelle un jeu à somme
nulle pareille aux échecs il n'y a pas
de coopération en tournoi s'ils jouent
bas je marque un point et vous 0 et
réciproquement
et s'il ya match nul on marque 1 2
minutes chacun les échecs c'est ce qu'on
appelle un jeu à somme constante c'est à
dire que le nombre de points à
distribuer et toujours le même d'une
partie à l'autre
il ya juste la répartition qui change
dans les jeux à somme nulle où assomme
constantin servian même n'y a pas de
notion de coopération
par contre dans un jeu comme le dilemme
du prisonnier on peut avoir intérêt à
coopérer et la raison c'est que ça n'est
pas un jeu à somme constante
regardez dans cette situation ce sont
six points qui seront distribués au
total
dans celle-ci 5 et dans celle ci
seulement deux points
la somme que se partagent les joueurs
n'est pas constante elle dépend des
choix et le choix coopératif est
globalement plus attractif puisque c'est
suite il distribue le plus de points
mais on a vu qu'il n'est pas
nécessairement le choix qui va s'imposer
à cause de la tentation de trahir par
égoïsme ce genre de situation a
notamment été théorisée par le
mathématicien john nash que vous
connaissez peut-être si vous avez vu le
film
un homme d'exception qui lui est
consacré john nash avait notamment
remarqué que quand les deux joueurs
trahissent ils sont dans une espèce de
situation d' équilibre stable
si un des joueurs décident de modifier
sa position et ben il ne peut que y
perdre c'est à dire qu aucun des joueurs
n'a intérêt à bouger
s'il est le seul à le faire on appelle
ça un équilibre de nash est ici
l'equilibre de nash est une situation
qui est globalement défavorable ces
situations un peu théorique on modélise
en théorie des jeux ont plein
d'applications concrètes et on va en
voir quelques unes
prenons un exemple imaginons vous êtes
au lycée et vous avez un dossier à
préparer pour faire un exposé sur un
sujet quelconque et on vous demande de
faire ça par groupe de deux en binôme
chacun des deux élèves a le choix entre
travailler sérieusement ça c'est le
choix coopératif ou bien glandouiller en
espérant que l'autre fasse le boulot ça
c'est en quelque sorte la trahison
au global la solution coopérative est
évidemment la meilleure si l'un des deux
seulement glandouille et bien l'autre se
fait avoir en se tapant tout le boulot
mais si les deux glandouiller bas il se
retrouve avec un dossier pourri
une des raisons qui a notamment poussé
au développement de la théorie des jeux
c'est la situation qui existait entre
les etats-unis et la russie pendant la
guerre froide
imaginons deux pays en concurrence
chacun des deux a le choix entre
consacré son argent à l'armement ou bien
à des trucs plus utile comme l'éducation
les infrastructures la culture etc
si les deux investissent dans
l'éducation passé globalement la
meilleure solution si les deux
investissent dans l'armement bas c'est
la guerre froide et quelque part tout le
monde y perd un peu mais si un seul des
deux a investi dans l'armement il peut
envahir l'autre pays qui se retrouvent
détruits autre exemple en matière
d'économie cette fois imaginons deux
entreprises qui fournissent à peu près
le même produit
on va dire des abonnements de téléphone
portable et qui auraient chacun la
moitié du marché
chacune des deux entreprises am et ont
le choix entre monter ses prix ou
baisser ses prix si les deux décident de
baisser leurs prix c'est ce qu'on
appelle une guerre des prix les
positions de marché restent identiques
mais leurs bénéfices fondre
si l'une des deux entreprises baisse ses
prix et l'autre les montes celle qui a
baissé pique tous les clients prend tout
le marché et l'autre entreprise cool
mais si les deux entreprises montrent
leurs prix les positions de marché reste
stable mais elles vont toutes les deux
augmenter leurs bénéfices
c'est la solution coopérative la
meilleure pour tout le monde
enfin pour tout le monde sauf pour les
clients évidemment qui seront pigeonner
dans ce cas là pour eux la situation de
guerre des prix est bien plus
souhaitable et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que les ententes sur les prix sont
sévèrement punies par les autorités de
régulation de la concurrence
mais les exemples d'applications la
théorie des jeux ne se limite pas aux
situations où il ya deux camps ça marche
aussi quand il ya plein de participants
a étonné vous pouvez faire le jeu
suivant avec des amis mettez un groupe
autour d'une table chacun a le choix
entre misé 0 10 euro mais quand on
choisit sa mise
on ne sait pas ce que les autres vont
faire puis on révèle les mises on les
rassemble et le total est doublé par la
banque avant d'être répartis
équitablement entre tous les joueurs
indépendamment de leur mise et d'amandes
collectivement on a intérêt à ce que
tout le monde mise pour augmenter la
part de l'argent reversé mais
individuellement chacun se dit qu'il a
intérêt à mettre zéro vu que l'argent à
la fin sera de toute façon répartis
entre tout le monde
ce petit jeu symbolise toutes les
situations dites de passager clandestin
où quelqu'un se dit qu'il peut frauder
parce que la collectivité payera pour
lui alors la fraude dans les transports
évidemment mais aussi la fraude fiscale
mais ça ne se limite pas seulement à la
fraude ça concerne par exemple aussi la
pollution
si collectivement on doit réduire notre
niveau de pollution mais que chacun se
dit que sa contribution est négligeable
et que c'est pas bien grave s'ils
polluent
on est dans une situation de ce genre le
principe des jeux à sommes non dues là
aussi est exploité pour faire des
émissions de télé il y en avait une en
grande bretagne à une dizaine d'années
qui s'appelait golden balls et le
principe était qu'après avoir amassé un
pactole deux joueurs devaient se
partager selon une situation proche du
dilemme du prisonnier
alors voilà comment ça se passe les deux
joueurs sont assis autour d'une table et
chacun à deux boules dorées à
l'intérieur desquelles sont inscrits les
mots partagés et volé et ils
sélectionnent chacun une des deux boules
pour indiquer leur choix
si les deux joueurs choisissent partager
eh bien ils se partagent le magot à 50
50 si les deux choisissent de voler
personne ne reçoit rien et si l'un
décide de voler et l'autre de partager
le voleur prend tout le magot et le
partage heures repart les mains vides
[Applaudissements]
et comme pour le dilemme du prisonnier
c'est un jeu à somme non constante
la solution collaborative et globalement
la meilleure mais la trahison est
tentante et risque de mener à la pire
solution dans le jeu golden balls en
moyenne 53 % des gens choisissaient de
partager et 47% de trahir ça fait quand
même pas mal de trahison mais dans
golden balls comme dans les exemples
précédents il ya deux choses importantes
à prendre en compte le fait qu'on ne
joue qu'une seule fois
une fois que le coup est joué on se
quitte et on se revoit plus donc déjà la
trahison est pas trop pesant
psychologiquement
et puis il ya pas de notion de confiance
qui peut s'installer là où ça devient
intéressant c'est quand on s'amuse à
répéter le même jeu plusieurs fois de
suite et à regarder comment les
comportements des joueurs évoluent vous
vous souvenez mon jeu du passager
clandestin celui on a un groupe de
personnes qui peuvent choisir de miser
soit 0 soit 10 euros et où la somme est
doublé avant d'être partagée entre tous
le monde
si vous amuser à jouer à ce jeu avec des
amis essayez de faire plusieurs tours ce
que vous allez constater c'est que dans
les premiers tours la plupart des gens
vous misez et puis plus il ya de
fraudeurs plus ça incite les autres a
fraudé ou en tout cas ça décourage les
autres de coopérer et au bout de
quelques tours tout le monde mise 0 dans
le dilemme du prisonnier aussi on peut
répéter le jeu plusieurs fois de suite
et cumuler les points et c'est
intéressant parce que ça permet aux
joueurs de varier leurs coûts par
exemple en fumée l'adversaire avec une
trahison après une série de coopération
ou au contraire montré de la bonne
volonté et revenir à la coopération
après une trahison pour jouer au dilemme
du prisonnier répété il faut définir une
stratégie c'est-à-dire une série de
consignes qui vont vous permettre de
décider comment vous allez jouer votre
coup en fonction des coûts qui ont été
joués avant par vous et par l'adversaire
voilà une série de stratégies possibles
il ya la stratégie dite gentille qui
consiste à toujours coopéré et ne jamais
trahir
on peut l'appeler aussi la stratégie
naïve à l'opposé il ya la stratégie
méchante qui consiste à trahir à tous
les tours quoi qu'il arrive il ya la
stratégie indécise dans laquelle on
alterne coopérer et trahir la stratégie
méfiante dans laquelle on alterne aussi
mais en commençant par une trahison
et puis il ya la stratégie lunatique où
on tire au hasard
toutes ces stratégies sont très simples
mais pas très intéressante notamment
parce qu'elles ne tiennent pas compte de
la manière dont l'adversaire joue voici
quelques exemples de stratégies qui
s'adapte à l'adversaire la stratégie
rancunière qui consiste à coopérer tout
le temps jusqu'à ce que l'adversaire
trahissent et à partir du moment où il a
trahi une foule
on le travaille jusqu'à la fin des temps
on peut imaginer aussi des choses plus
compliquées du genre coopérer sauf si
l'adversaire a trahi deux fois de suite
auquel cas trahir aussi mais au bout de
trois trahisons successives on revient à
une coopération et on peut imaginer des
tas de stratégie de ce genre alors pour
savoir quelles étaient les meilleures
le mathématicien robert axelrod a eu
l'idée d'organiser un grand tournoi
il a demandé à une soixantaine de
personnes des mathématiciens des
psychologues des physiciens de lui
soumettre des stratégies et les a fait
tout ça front t deux par deux dans un
grand tournoi informatique et il a
compté les points accumulés par chaque
stratégie et la grande stratégie
gagnante
une stratégie complètement inattendue
d'une simplicité enfantine elle a été
soumise par un théoricien des jeux
anatole rapporte et la voici au premier
coup coopérer et pour le reste du jeu
répétez le coup que l'adversaire a joué
au tour précédent hyper simple si
l'adversaire à coopérer aux coups
précédents vous coopérez et s'il a trahi
et aux coups précédents
vous trahissez c'est tout cette
stratégie est surnommé donnant donnant
la stratégie donnant donnant et celle
qui a cumulé le plus de points sur la
totalité du tournoi organisé par robert
axelrod
mais ce qui est amusant c'est qu'elle
n'a gagné aucun de ses matchs souvenez
vous un ce tournoi c'est en fait une
série de duels où les différentes
stratégies s'affrontent deux par deux et
bien chaque fois qu'elle joue contre une
autre stratégie la stratégie
donnant-donnant fera moins de points
qu'elle ou autant à la limite mais elle
ne gagne jamais le match mais en
cumulant tous les matches c'est elle qui
totalise le plus de points à l'opposé
une stratégie comme la stratégie
méchante qui consiste à travers tout le
temps ne va perdre aucun de ses matchs
mehal accumulera très peu de points
et oui ces résultats un peu paradoxaux
sont possibles parce qu'on a là un jeu à
somme non constante le nombre de points
distribués n'est pas toujours le même et
donc gagner ses duels et accumulé plein
de points ce n'est pas la même chose il
est intéressant d'analyser plus en
détail la stratégie donnant-donnant pour
essayer de comprendre pourquoi elle
marche si bien
bon déjà c'est une stratégie qui
commence toujours par coopérer c'est à
dire qu'elle est bienveillant elle est
optimiste mais à côté de ça allait pas
naïve non plus c'est à dire qu'elle
n'hésite pas à trahir si jamais elle a
été trahie mais à la fin c'est une
stratégie qui est juste qui est pas
fourbe elle va pas s'amuser à trahir si
tout se passe bien et que tout le monde
coopère mais le point le plus
intéressant c'est que c'est une
stratégie dite
à mémoire courte elle ne se base que sur
le coup précédent pour décider de ce
qu'elle va faire
elle ignore complètement le passé même
si l'adversaire a coopéré plein de fois
s'il trahit il sera punir mais
inversement même si l'adversaire a trahi
des dizaines de fois s'il revient à la
coopération
on coopère en oubliant le passé la
punition est immédiate mais le pardon
est aussi et il est inconditionnelle en
pratique nous les humains on a du mal à
adopter ce genre de comportement on
évite rancunier et c'est pas facile de
regagner votre confiance je pense qu'il
ya quand même un principe intéressant à
méditer pour les relations humaines
que ce soit en famille ou au boulot
punition immédiate mais pardon
inconditionnels utile pour l'éducation
des enfants dont le couple aussi
peut-être
pensez-y aussi si vous êtes dans un
environnement de travail qui vous semble
compétitif le boulot c'est souvent un
jeu à somme non constante et c'est pas
celui qui écrasera tous ses adversaires
qui marquera le plus de points à la fin
merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo si elle
vous a plu n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
à la chaîne si ce n'est pas déjà fait
pour ne rien rater
vous pouvez retrouver les actus de la
chaîne sur facebook et sur twitter et
ceux qui le souhaitent peuvent vous
soutenir sur tipis et puis pour ceux qui
voudraient aller un petit peu plus loin
sur la théorie des jeux j'ai écrit un
billet sur mon blog qui détaille
quelques trucs dont j'ai pas le temps de
parler
merci à bientôt
[Musique]